okay so let me talk a little bit about
why we are talking about transcriptomic
data in the context of drug discovery
drug repurposing and personalized
medicine
so as you know bioinformatics plays a
critical role in modern drug discovery
repurposing
biomarker screening and design of
personalized treatment regimens and so
many industries and research labs are
actually seeking out experts that are
knowledgeable in onyx data processing
analysis and integration and there are
many different challenges as well as
opportunities in being able to integrate
analyze and
turn this data into a model that could
be used to design further experiments
now a lot of this is based on omics data
and the term omics actually means a lot
of different types of data and so this
program is going to be focused on
transcriptomic data but the program that
we are a part of today is covering
several different elements of data that
i think are important to understand
so one example is phenomics and this
means phenotypic data that can include
cell morphology
the way that cells shape right different
cells have very different
shapes and they are dysregulated in
different ways we can also talk about
genomic data right so the sequences of
nucleotides and amino acids typically
referred to as genomic data
epigenomic data which is a field that
has been growing very fast since about
2007 2008 where we see an increase in
the appreciation of how
translation of sequences to mrna and
proteins is an important component of
non-hereditary
regulation of
genomic sequencing
data
and finally what we will be focusing on
in this program is the transcriptomic
data and so this program on
transcriptomic data analysis is an
important part because it provides a
real in-depth view
of how we can use
gene expression and isoform expression
patterns for discovery of biomarkers for
understanding of drug targets and for
being able to perform
analysis of
drug function based on expression of
mrna in different forms
so
in this program which is called rna
sequencing for drug discovery and
repurposing we will look for how people
use transcriptomic data to link targets
to diseases
validate these targets and explore their
variation in the natural systems biology
and so
i think that this really uh brings into
the spotlight this new era of drug
discovery where transcriptomics could be
used for discovery of new compounds and
complex molecules like proteins that can
control disease through the regulation
of gene expression that essentially
mimic the mechanism by which our bodies
exert regulatory control over a range of
normal and disease functions and so to
speak a little bit about why
next generation sequencing and what this
term means and how we can use
specifically this kind of data let me
briefly talk about the history behind
next generation sequencing and other
forms of measurement for mrna and this
will help us see why we can actually use
not just any type of
mrna measurement tool but specifically
next generation sequencing
so as a method of measuring rna
translation
transcriptomic studies can help detect
mrna expression inside the cell as an
accurate alternative to membrane protein
expression
detection which allows for molecular
precision in diagnostics and even
development of treatment based on
molecular pathways so what you can see
here is the expression of the her2
surface protein
which could be a measurement a detection
of that protein essentially tells us
something about the property of the cell
and about the in the processes inside
the cell or subcellular molecular
processes that are so important for
understanding of that tissue condition
and potential
response to drug treatment
so
when we think about our ability to
detect such protein surfaces there are
actually several different techniques to
do that
uh and uh before we get to rna
sequencing we can talk about one of
these technologies which is microarray
technologies
so the microarray technologies allow us
to hybridize sequences of mrnas or
actual transcripts in these flow cells
that then we can extract rna from cells
or tissues and then see which ones bind
together to these uh small sequences to
measure abundance of specific
molecules that we are interested in
now as opposed to microarray next
generation sequencing actually has
revolutionized the way that we can look
at transcriptomes because they provide
us with so many
novel insights about what's actually
going on
one we don't have to perform a
preparation technique that creates the
assay we just measure all the mrna that
is present inside the cell and then we
can analyze what kind of alternative
splicing events are happening so what
types of isoforms are being generated
what types of genes are being expressed
and then how can we combine or look
separately at these two different types
of data to make informed decisions about
the types of samples that we are looking
at
so what we'll talk about in this program
is our ability to leverage
this kind of big data
and see the significance of mrna
expression in the context of data
integration which is really the frontier
that drug discovery drug repurposing and
personalized treatment deals with
so what's important here is that you
will find many interesting and important
biomedical projects that can leverage
rna-seq data for diagnostics and cancer
biology understanding
for disease classification and patient
stratification which are so important
for clinical trials and understanding of
real patient populations that need to be
treated
as well as single cell and tissue
composition so we will be able to look
at how single cell
and different types of immune cells
different types of
tissues actually represent
a heterogeneous composition of cells
with different properties that need to
be deconvoluted for us to be able to
apply
meaningful drug discovery and screening
as well as biomarker and precision
medicine targeting of novel treatments
to the program page